كان يتحدث الدكتور اشرف وكنا نتحدث معك عن
وصول
النازحين الى رفح ومنهم المصابين وحتى
الشهداء الى المستشفى حيث تقف ومستشفى
كمال عدوان ايضا بفعل عدم قدره النازحين
والمصابين وحتى من ينتشرون الشهداء الى
الوصول الى مستشفى ناصر والامل الذي بات
محاصرا هل ما زالت عمليه التدفق والوصول
متاحه باتجاه رفح رغم يعني هذه الطرق
الصعبه والمسافه الطويله
محمد في كل دقيقه الوضع يتغير الجيش
الاسرائيلي يغير ويتم وضع ويتمركز في
مناطق مختلفه وبالتالي هذه الطرق مازالت
تحت نيران قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الجيش
الاسرائيلي يكثف من عمليات القصف يكثف من
عمليات اطلاق النار الطائرات المسيره ايضا
تطلق النار على المواطنين الذين يحاولون
حتى النزوح من تلك المناطق التي طلب الجيش
الاسرائيلي من هؤلاء السكان ان يتوجهوا
الى مدينه رفح الجيش الاسرائيلي يبلغ عن
مربعات سكنيه ويطلب منهم الخروج من هذه
المربعات السكنيه اما الى منطقه المواصي
في خانيونس التي يقصفها وقصفها ووصل عدد
من الشهداء الى مدينه رفح الى مستشفى ابو
يوسف النجار او حتى يطلب منهم بالتالي
التوجه الى مدينه رفح لكن رغم كل ذلك هو
يغلق هذه الطرقات الزملاء توجهوا عبر طرق
التفافه طويله و حتى هذه الطرق الالتفاف
التي توجهوا منها ما ان وصلوا الى مدينه
رفح حتى ابلغنا ان هذاه الطرق لم تعد
متاحه لان الجيش الاسرائيلي يطلق النار
على المواطنين الذين يحاولون الخروج من
هذه الطرق كان شارع رقم خمسه هو الشارع
الاساسي والرئيسي الذي يستخدمه السكان في
خانيونس من اجل التوجه الى مدينه حمد ومن
ثم الانطلاق غربا الى شارع الرشيد ومن ثم
الى شارع من شارع الرشيد الى مدينه رفح
لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي الان يتمركز ويتم
وضع في مناطق مختلفه ويطلق النار على
الشارع الاساسي الرئيسي وهو شارع رقم خمسه
الذين الذي يستخدمه السكان من اجل الخروج
من مدينه خانيونس الى رفح وبالتالي الخروج
بات صعبا بل يكاد يكون مستحيلا في ظل هذه
الظروف واستمرار اطلاق النار واستمرار
اطلاق القذائف باتجاه المواطنين في هذا
الشارع الاساسي والرئيسي الاخطر من كل ذلك
ان السكان حتى في منطقه المواصي هم
مستهدفون الجيش الاسرائيلي يتوغل وتوغل
بالامس باتجاه جامعه الاقصى ويطلق القذائف
باتجاه المواطنين المتواجدين في الخيام في
منطقه المواصي ونحن نتحدث عن منط منطقه
المواصي بكل تاكيد هذه المنطقه التي منذ
اليوم الاول للحرب الاسرائيليه والجيش
الاسرائيلي يميزها على الخرائط التي
ينشرها ويتحدث انها منطقه انسانيه ويطلب
من السكان ان يتوجهوا الى المنطقه
الانسانيه وبعد ذلك قصفهم وقصف هذه الخيام
التي المتواجده في هذه المنطقه التي يتحدث
انها انسانيه ومن المعلوم ان هذه المنطقه
يتواجد ايضا فيها مقرات نقلت المؤسسات
الدوليه جميع مقراتها الى هذه المنطقه
منطقه المواسم مواص رفح ومواص خانيونس
وبالتالي هي مقرات تابعه للمؤسسات الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر للرو والكثير من المؤسسات
اتخذت من المنازل واتخذت من الشاليهات
السياحيه في تلك المنطقه بالتالي مقرات
لها وبالتالي هذه حتى المقرات باتت مهدده
بفعل استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي في تلك
المناطق ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي تقدم صباح
هذا اليوم باتجاه شارع الرشيد وكانت
الدبابات هناك واطلقت النار والقذائف
باتجاه ال السيارات المدنيه الفلسطينيه
التي كانت قادمه من مناطق الوسط او من
مناطق مدينه خانيونس باتجاه مدينه رفح
وحتى بالتالي الطريق الوحيد الذي ما زال
مستمرا ويعمل باتجاه مناطق وسط القطاع هو
الان مهدد بفعل استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي
وباستمرار التوغل وعندما نتحدث عن شارع
الرشيد نحن نتحدث عن شارع واحد ووحيد الان
يفصل ويمر من خلاله المساعدات باتجاه
مناطق الوسط باتجاه مدينه خان يونس الان
المساعدات لا تستطيع الوصول الى مدينه
خانيونس وبالتالي ايضا هي الان مهدده من
قطع الامدادات باتجاه مناطق الوسط
وبالتالي مناطق الوسط تكون محاصره ايضا ما
بين مدينه خانيونس التي قطعها الجيش
الاسرائيلي وما بين مدينه غزه التي قطع
الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ بدايه عمليات التوغل
الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه قطع الطريق الواصل
ما بين مدينه غزه ووسط القطاع طريقين
اساسيين هما شارع صلاح الدين وشارع الرشيد
وهما مفصولين الان ب من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بالتالي الجيش الاسرائيلي يضيق
الخناق على قطاع غزه يضيق الخناق على
سكانه حتى وصلت الاوضاع الى حد المجاعه في
شمال القطاع ومدينه غزه نحن نتحدث عن
مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع الذين ما زال
السكان يتواجدون فيها والجيش الاسرائيلي
يكثف من عملياته منذ عده ايام في تلك
المنطقه وبالتالي الناس الان لا تستطيع
الحصول لا على الغذاء ولا على الدواء ولا
على اي شيء يمكن ان يبقيهم على قيد الحيا
من رفح هشام زقوت شكرا جز لك